I've always loved science since I was a
child I've been fascinated by
understanding what things are made of
and motivated by curiosity to find out
for myself
children are naturally curious investing
in this instinct is the best training
for scientists to make breakthroughs
that have the potential to help us live
better healthier and more fulfilling
lives it's interesting and noble work
and it was the prospect of becoming a
scientist that led me to study maths
physics and chemistry at school but
after that as a woman that's where I
became a bit unusual because I went on
to study chemistry at University all
children study science to some level at
school but when it comes to studying the
sciences in higher education the
proportion of young women drops
dramatically we're working hard to
address that at the Science Museum group
but what else can be done to increase
gender equality in science technology
engineering and mathematics the STEM
subjects what we need to do is show them
role models of girls like them
personality like them friendly outgoing
bubbly creative and show actually women
like that do just like them do really
well in science technology and
engineering a happy find something
they're interested in excited by to
break down those stereotypes to show
them people just like them actually do
thrive in these industries the history
of science is littered with intrepid
endeavors and amazing discoveries
most of the best-known made by men full
of female name stick in my mind
people like Ada Lovelace the 19th
century mathematician who worked on a
mechanical general-purpose computer
valentina Tereshkova the first woman in
space who remains the only one ever to
complete a solo mission Amy Johnson the
first female pilot to fly a plane solo
from Britain to Australia and British
Nobel prize-winning chemist Dorothy
Hodgkin whose discoveries remain
critical to modern medicine and our
scientific understanding recently we've
seen the opportunities and support for
today's women in science growth and the
chances to establish long and successful
careers increase we need to build on
that we find that there are still much
fewer women at the higher levels of an
academic research career and this is I
think because so many have taken a break
and that break can be for family reasons
it can be for caring it can be for
health or relocation indeed with a with
a partner but what a lot of people don't
realize is that there is a way back in
initiatives like the government's year
of engineering and this the science
museums engineer your future gallery
show that women are contributing to and
leading some of the most important
scientific and technical advances today
but we can and must do more to show
girls and women that science truly is
for them well I'm delighted to say that
Dame Mary joins me now alongside
professor Averell McDonald at
Southampton University who's the
diversity lead at the southeast physics
Network and an old friend of the program
Edwina Dunn she's found a female lead
and the founder of Dunn humbie the
company behind worldwide loyalty
programs such as Tesco's club cars and
also with us live from Westminster is a
science minister Sam gamer Mary let me
start with you this is not a new problem
why are we making such slow progress
well we are making some progress
numbers are up in general though there
is a big black hole on physics why I
don't know I think there are deep-seated
cultural differences about bringing up
girls and bringing up boys also
stereotypes of scientists and science
can be way behind reality and people
have no idea that diversity of careers
that are open to them if they keep up
their stem and close to them if they
don't they will there's been some really
interesting research done on
participation rates at school and
immediately afterwards it's physics and
maths in particularly those STEM isn't
the right necessarily the right category
here is it absolutely if we look at stem
overall actually girls are increasing
participation and even in maths they're
way above 40 percent today level and
degree level so there's an awful lot of
progress but stubbornly physics has
remained at about 20% of those taking a
level of physical and 20% at degree
level or female and that's despite since
the 1980s now nearly 40 years of effort
on our part we have not made any
progress something fundamentally is
going wrong and it's not as if though
girls are avoiding so-called hard
subjects if you take things like
veterinary science and medical science
at university women are way in the
ascendancy sixty-five percent of medical
students are female now so they're
certainly not avoiding the hard subjects
and it is something that's peculiar to
the UK if you look across Europe we are
the worst in a long way behind all of
the other countries in terms of the
number of women in STEM careers it's
what we do that is the problem so
somewhere along the line it looks as
though we are reinforcing gender
stereotypes here in the UK about these
subjects I think so I mean you know
girls need to see role models that they
believe they can be one day so you know
we have this saying you can't be what
you can't see so we're trying to take
the female lead with it's 60 amazing
role models into we're now in 3,000
schools in the UK
and girls teachers parents are beginning
to talk to us and saying it's wonderful
we now can see that there are lots of
ways of having a career that's both
feminine and exciting and successful I
think models role models out there I
mean as some of them have been
intimidating maybe that's very true
but the the thing about diversity the
thing about having 60 very very
different women
his girls can pick the one that they
relate to so we have one very very
popular woman who is a ballerina she's
absolutely an incredible Michaela de
Prince and you know so many girls want
to be a ballerina or a princess when
they're young she's just happened to be
the prima ballerina in the Royal Dutch
Ballet and has come a very very long way
and so shows a different type of success
all right well Sam Jean let me bring you
in at this point you've you've become
University's Minister relatively
recently have you formed a diagnosis in
your own mind as to how to tackle this
issue yet well the first point I will
say about this is um when it comes to
innovation when it comes to
breakthroughs its scientists and people
in engineering and mats that are the
forefront of it so as a country and as a
society we need a lot more people doing
this and it's not an issue of fairness
but actually getting talented women
through is actually good for our economy
and good for our country in terms of
what I'm seeing is I think what you need
is you need a sustainable pipeline of
talent but although we've seen an
increase in the number of girls take in
size related subjects at every stage of
the process you have leakage so even if
I look at apprenticeships and its
national apprenticeship this week after
all the number of women in STEM related
apprenticeships is something like eleven
percent according to some independent
research the number of women who qualify
within stem degrees but they're going to
have a stem career it's something like
twenty four percent so I haven't got a
diagnosis per se but what I do know is
that the industrial strategy that the
government is pursuing
very much at its heart getting the right
talent to help solve the challenges that
we face in our country and in the world
today but I mean is there anything wrong
with the way some of these subjects are
being taught at universities you've just
mentioned the dropout rates there for
example I mean it you're going to be
cracking the whip on certain Vice
Chancellors well I think it's and there
are many different reasons and I think
is Mary who talked about some of the
deep-seated cultural reasons around
subject choice but also how careers in
science operates so if you want to work
inside the nature of the contracts are
the contracts structured in such a way
that if you wanted to take time out of
work for our to have children they can
easily come back you know the emphasis
on research and research citations how
does that actually help support women
scientists in their careers there are
lots of different things and I think it
will take a concerted effort you're
right at university level research
councils but also from employers to make
sure that we do not have what in America
they call the loss Einsteins they're
really talented people who could help
sort of great problems for us who just
don't make it all right Sam I'm going to
ask her Averell to put a question to you
directly now April came to make sure we
don't have the Lost Einsteins but I'm
very aware that we have a system in the
UK that could well be losing a lot of
them not just girls but children from
ethnic minority groups as well and
that's the fact that they have to make a
choice at 14 also to take triple Awards
three separate Sciences or double award
a combined science now schools are now
rationing access to that triple award
the separate Sciences which tends to be
the springboard to a level because they
can't afford more than one set and an
awful lot of the kids who are not
allowed to take the triple are from
ethnic minority groups
disproportionately and girls that means
a lot of loss scientists are being
prevented from going to a level because
the school can't afford to get them into
the right classes at the age of fourteen
now are we aware of a way of getting
around this because I would suggest just
getting rid of triple awards so that no
child is disadvantaged at 14 and they
all get to 16 with exactly the same
opportunities and then that
discrimination wouldn't happen
I'd be interested in your view on that
well this is a quite a well rehearsed
argument on of our triples
science versus double science I think
what is what is important throughout the
school system is making sure that
everyone understands the rules of the
game and as you say some well of our
children understand the rules of the
game much sooner and know that if I want
to keep my options open I should go down
this path and things like the careers in
enterprise company that the government
set up which is going into schools to
stimulate people's interest to raise
aspirations are all things that are
they're very useful in making children
understand from very early age what is
out there but also what one needs to do
to rearm realize your aspirations if
your aspirations lie in that field I
wouldn't say that somehow our education
system systematically makes it difficult
for children from ethnic minority
backgrounds but I think more needs to be
done in terms of letting them know what
the rules of the game are Mary what do
you make of what you've just heard very
interesting and I would hesitate to do
away with the triple award I must say
because you know there's a lot to learn
in science and you might as well do away
with English like language or English
literature if you I mean you've got to
allow some specialization anyway I'm not
going to be arguing I meant to be
addressing you Minister so I guess my
question is about the role of informal
learning in science so in the Science
Museum group we have two million
children come with their moms and their
dads all the school teachers every year
a tremendous opportunity for us to like
that spark but of course really to get
qualified in science you've got to do
some formal education what do you think
the role of I'm afraid we're going to
have to leave that question hanging in
the air because we're out of time I'm
afraid
Averell McDonald
Edwina Don and Sam Jima in most
Westminster thanks very much all